[MUSIC PLAYING]
RETO MEIER: Hi, I'm Reto Meier,
Google Developer Advocate,
and I'm still here
with Dave Renson,
director of Customer
Reliability Engineering.
So, Dave, I've always
thought of SREs
as the first responders
in the computing world.
When everything is catching
fire and falling down,
you guys are running in.
Has there ever been a situation
where you wanted to turn around
and run the other way?
DAVE RENSON: You
mean, like, when
a hurricane was threatening
to wipe most of the Eastern
seaboard off the map?
RETO MEIER: Yes,
exactly like that.
What does preparation for
something like that look like?
Inflatable life
rafts, life jackets?
DAVE RENSON: It's a little
more involved than that.
But, if you want to
hear the whole story,
and more, join us
at Google Next,
at the 5th Nine Lounge,
a dedicated space
for SRE and DevOps people,
where you'll hear all the
wonderful, wild, wacky,
sometimes just plain weird
stories of what it's like to
run a production system at web
scale.
RETO MEIER: We look
forward to seeing you then.
[MUSIC PLAYING]